what we're covering today is a rule of
quantum mechanics we haven't met before
that is responsible for a lot of the
weirdness it explains the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle but even more
importantly explains why a superposition
is different from not knowing what an
object is doing I know I've been away
for a while so if you need to refresh on
any of that old stuff do that first
because we'll need it and if anything is
confusing in this video let me know
because I'll do a few follow-up videos
trying to make this idea clearer it's
kind of an important one say there's
some object you're interested in then
there are all these things you can ask
about what it's doing for example where
is it how fast is it going how much is
it spinning etc we'll call all these
things that you can measure about an
object its observables
usually we think an object has a value
for each of these but quantum mechanics
instead says that each object is in a
superposition of all the values it can
have in the regular rules different
observables can be independent for
example position and speed
this means that knowing an object's
position doesn't say anything about how
fast it's going so if you want me to
tell you what the object is doing it's
clearly not enough for me to just say
where it is now how can we translate
that to quantum mechanics say I have a
particle and you're interested in
observable X for that particle again
that can be position I can't tell you
where the object is the best I can do is
tell you the wavefunction right because
if you know that you'll know the
probabilities for all the places it can
turn up when measured but say you're
also interested in some other observable
Y again this can be the object's speed
you know that that must be in a
superposition as well and so you want to
know what that wave function is but x
and y are independent and so there's no
way of knowing without asking me except
this is totally not the case in quantum
mechanics and it's surprising you
actually can find out what the Y wave
function is
just by using the information from the
x1 in fact the way physicists like to
think of it is there is only one
wavefunction and it knows everything
there is to know about the particle and
it's possible to write that whole wave
function in terms of any observable you
want you might be thinking that this
difference between classical physics and
quantum mechanics is a slight technical
curiosity that only a physicists could
get excited about fair enough but I hope
to show you that it has some pretty
amazing consequences firstly it helps us
understand superposition we said that
while nobody is looking an object is in
a superposition of all possible States
for observable X when we measure X it
will collapse to one of those states
with probability given by the square of
the coefficient according to quantum
mechanics but this seems so complicated
why shouldn't we believe it's actually
just in one state or another with the
right probabilities but we just don't
know which both these explanations the
quantum mechanics superposition
crazyness 1 and the regular sensible one
both predict the same thing so shouldn't
we believe the simpler one the answer is
sure you can't tell the difference
between these two when you measure X but
if you measure Y instead these two
theories will make different predictions
and only quantum mechanics gets it right
we've met this once before and it's
called interference but we're finally
ready to explain it properly to
illustrate all this I'm going to use a
toy model that's nice and simple then
I'll explain how to do it in the really
interesting cases later say there's an
observable called
the up or down nosov a particle when you
measure it every particle is either up
or down
so in general quantum mechanics tells us
that they're in a superposition
but there's another property of a
particle that you can measure called its
left or right Ness and similarly the
particle can be in a superposition of
left and right I told you earlier that I
should be able to rewrite the wave
function in terms of any variable but
how
I convert from the wave function in
terms of up down s to left rightness or
in general how do I go from observable X
to Y first let's call each of these
states the eigenstates of X my task is
really to rewrite these in terms of the
eigenstates of Y and there is always a
set rule to do this in our case up
equals write plus left and down equals
right minus left I'll explain what
motivates these conversions when I do
some real examples but back to this toy
one if I had a particle that was up and
I decided to measure its left or right
Ness take a second to predict what would
happen and predict the same for the down
particle
the answer is for both cases there is a
50% chance of going left or right but
now here's the really tricky question
what if I had a particle that was in a
superposition of half up plus half down
if I measured its left or right Ness
what would happen think about it and
then click one of these options
you